an alle Leute die Bratwurst mögen jetzt
mal aufgepasst ich habe da für euch
nämlich mal was neues ausprobiert und
zwar ist das der gützler brattaler eine
Bratwurst in Form eines bratthalers
dafür erstmal ganz entspannt den Grill
vorheizen und die brathaler auf den
Grill packen vegane Sorte war bei the
way auch dabei und ja dann sah das noch
mal Zeit schon ziemlich schmackhaft aus
dann habe ich mich um die Brötchen
gekümmert halb aufschneiden und auch auf
dem Grill legen und dann kommt der
brattaler zwischen diese Brötchen kann
ich rauslutschen sorgt für keine Sauerei
eigentlich ziemlich nice dann einfach
schön belegen mit Soße eure Wahl ich
habe einfach Ketchup genommen und ja hab
reingebissen echt lecker also kann ich
empfehlen
[Musik]